gegenüber den tod feiern müssen wir uns
einschränken einschränken damit
krankheit und tod nicht über das leben
siegen
viele tausend sind gestorben
bei uns im eigenen land und in bergamo
im elsass in madrid new york und vielen
anderen orten auf der welt die bilder
gehen uns nah wir trauern um die die
einsam sterben wir denken an ihre
angehörigen die nicht einmal gemeinsam
abschied nehmen können und wir danken
den unermüdlichen lebensrettern im
gesundheitswesen so sehr unser aller
leben auf dem kopf steht
so denken wir insbesondere an die die
die krise besonders hart trifft die
krank oder einsam sind die sorgen haben
um den job um die firma die freiberufler
die künstler denen einnahmen wegbrechen
die familien die alleinerziehenden in
der engen wohnung ohne balkon und garten
die pandemie zeigt uns ja wir sind
verwundbar
vielleicht haben wir zu lange geglaubt
dass wir unverwundbar sind dass es immer
nur schneller höher weiter geht
aber das war ein irrtum die krise zeigt
uns allerdings nicht nur das sie zeigt
uns auch wie stark wir sind worauf wir
bauen können
ich bin tief beeindruckt von dem
kraftakt denn unser land in den
vergangenen wochen vollbracht hat noch
ist die gefahr nicht gebannt aber schon
heute können wir sagen jeder von ihnen
hat sein leben radikal geändert jeder
von ihnen hat dadurch menschenleben
gerettet und rette täglich mehr
es ist gut dass der staat jetzt
kraftvoll handelt in einer krise für die
es kein drehbuch gab
ich bitte sie auch alle weiteren um
vertrauen denn die regierenden im bund
und ländern wissen um ihre riesige
verantwortung
doch wie es jetzt weitergeht wann und
wie die einschränkungen gelockert werden
können darüber entscheiden nicht allein
politiker und experten sondern wir alle
haben das in der hand durch unsere
geduld und unsere disziplin gerade jetzt
wenn es uns am schwersten fällt den
kraftakt den wir in diesen tagen leisten
den leisten wir doch nicht weil eine
eiserne hand uns dazu zwingt sondern
weil wir eine lebendige demokratie mit
verantwortungsbewussten bürgern sind
eine demokratie in der wir einander zu
trauern auf fakten und argumente zu
hören vernunft zu zeigen das richtige zu
tun
eine demokratie in der jedes leben zählt
und der es auf jede und jeden ankommt
vom krankenpfleger bis zur
bundeskanzlerin vom expertenrat der
wissenschaft bis zu den sichtbaren und
unsichtbaren stützen der gesellschaft an
den supermarktkassen am lenkrad von bus
und lkw in der backstube auf dem
bauernhof oder bei der müllabfuhr so
viele von ihnen wachsen jetzt über sich
selbst hinaus ich danke ihnen dafür
und natürlich weiß ich wir alle sehnen
uns nach normalität
aber was heißt das eigentlich nur
möglichst schnell zurück in den alten
trott zu alten gewohnheiten nein die
welt danach wird eine andere sein wie
sie wird das liegt an uns lernen wir
doch aus den erfahrungen den guten wie
den schlechten die wir alle jeden tag in
dieser krise machen
ich glaube wir stehen jetzt an einer
wegscheide schon in der krise zeigen
sich die beiden richtungen die wir
nehmen können entweder jeder für sich
bogen raus hamstern und die eigenen
schäfchen ins trockene bringen
oder bleibt das neu erwachte engagement
für den anderen für die gesellschaft
bleibt die geradezu explodierende
kreativität und hilfsbereite bleiben wir
mit dem älteren nachbarn den wir beim
einkauf geholfen haben in kontakt
schenken wir der kassiererin und den
paketboten auch weiterhin die
wertschätzung die sie verdienen mehr
noch erinnern wir uns auch nach der
krise noch was unverzichtbare arbeit in
der pflege in der versorgung in den
sozialen berufen in kitas und schulen
was sie uns wirklich wert sein muss und
helfen die die es wirtschaftlich gut
durch die krise schaffen denen wieder
auf die beine
die besonders hart gefallen sind und
suchen wir auf der welt gemeinsam nach
dem ausweg oder fallen wir zurück in
abschottung und alleingänge teilen wir
doch alles wissen und alle forschung
damit wir schneller zu imker von
therapien gelangen und sorgen wir in
einer globalen allianz dafür dass auch
die ärmsten länder zugang haben die
länder die am verwundbarsten sind
nein diese pandemie ist kein krieg
nationen stehen nicht gegen nationen
soldaten nicht gegen soldaten sondern
sie ist eine prüfung unserer
menschlichkeit
sie ruft das schlechteste und das beste
in den menschen erfuhren zeigen wir
einander doch das beste in uns und
zeigen wir es bitte auch in europa
deutschland kann nicht stark und gesund
aus der krise kommen wenn unsere
nachbarn nicht auch stark und gesund
werden diese blaue fahne hier steht
nicht ohne grund dort 30 jahre nach der
deutschen einheit 75 jahre nach dem ende
des krieges sind wir deutsche zur
solidarität in europa
nicht nur aufgerufen wir sind dazu
verpflichtet solidarität ich weiß das
ist ein großes wort aber er fährt nicht
jeder und jede von uns derzeit ganz
konkret ganz existenziell was
solidarität bedeutet mein handeln ist
für andere überlebenswichtig bitte
bewahren wir uns diese kostbare
erfahrung die solidarität die sie jetzt
jeden tag beweisen die brauchen wir in
zukunft um summieren
wir werden nach dieser krise eine andere
gesellschaft sein
wir wollen keine ängstliche keine
misstrauische gesellschaft werden aber
wir können eine gesellschaft sein mit
mehr vertrauen mit mehr rücksicht und
mit mehr zuversicht ist dass selbst an
ostern zu viel der guten hoffnung
über diese frage hat das virus keine
macht darüber entscheiden allein wir
selbst vieles wird in der kommenden zeit
sicher nicht einfach aber wir deutschen
machen es uns ja auch sonst nicht immer
einfach hier verlangen uns selbst viel
ab und trauen einander viel zu wir
können und wir werden auch in dieser
lage wachsen
frohe ostern alles gute und geben wir
acht aufeinander
sie sahen eine ansprache des
bundespräsidenten
zahlen begleiten unser leben unsere
leidenschaft sind die zahlen der
finanzwelt
deshalb arbeiten wir seit über 60 jahren
daran mit investmentfonds mehr aus ihrem
geld zu machen ganz unabhängig von der
wetterlage union investment aus geld
zukunft machen
[Musik]